This Luthier was asked
what makes a good guitar
and the answer was a good person.
And I really liked that. I think it's...
The personality of the maker
comes through in the instrument.
The Leonardo Guitar Research Project
is a three-year project
to investigate the use
of non-tropical woods in guitar-making.
Tropical woods are very common
and are almost seen as necessary
for guitar-making.
And what we're trying to show
is that that may not be the case -
that we can build perfectly good guitars
with non-tropical woods.
There are three schools
involved in the project.
There's Newark School in England,
there's CMB in Belgium
and IKATA in Finland.
So far, we've had two workshops.
There's been great interaction between
the students from the different schools.
They're getting on very well
and exchanging a lot of ideas.
For the purpose
of this week's workshop,
we've samples of several species
of non-tropical wood
and we're testing the workability
of the woods -
how easy they are
to plane, saw, drill, fret, bend.
We're testing their flexibility
and also sound transmission.
We have four entrepreneurial Luthiers
involved in the project
and their role is
to host a kind of apprenticeship
just for a week or two.
So, the craft skills are important,
but equally important
is the business side of things,
which enables the Luthier
to make a living.
The school is a place of education
and the broader that education can be,
the more useful it is.
What the Erasmus+ project
enables us to do
is collaborate in a way
that we all learn from each other.
It expands the horizons of each school
and I think it helps the students
to feel like part of community.